we train hard we ready we don't know
love just show us the dance floor you
are your game face on it right in London
hubli deadly I pity the poor competition
its own nah I've been keeping this quiet
for about a couple of months I'm ready
retri loose release the anger release
the beasts ah look at all the
competition I'm a scary of him know he's
like it to Eddie and the Beast she's the
beauty she gonna teach me all the things
when I can finally get a chance to be
silly to be to be happy and all that
stuff the base of my life I had to be
tough bodyguarding bouncer ba Baracus
clubber lang knocking dance for the kids
the people can see me in a different
light you're gonna help fun you're gonna
have a lot of fun okay so tell me how
did this come about is this like a show
that you always wanted to do or did
somebody have to be like I you gotta do
this no no I'm glad you brought it up I
have been resisted it so like love say
no no not now not not no no that they've
been asking me about 10 years and I can
see it now truthfully and a lot of time
I resisted I told the truth I said more
people get hurt on Dancing with the
Stars then MMA you don't mean because a
lot of people they don't understand it
takes a lot of work a lot of heat on
saying that so if I'm ready for it I'm
ready for the work I'm ready for the
workout you're gonna train hard we're
gonna prepare ourself hard if we don't
win is that because we didn't try we're
gonna give it our best shot you know
that's all we can do they'll do our best
I ain't gonna use the excuses I'm ready
to roll I'm giving my best shot I'm
gonna do what I can that's all you can
do so I'm not scared of no dance even
though i don't have known how to do none
of them you know but I'm ready to do
them that's all everybody's calling
dancing it's not called walking it's
called dancing so we're gonna dance the
hully gully whatever we do we're just
gonna day is
[Music]
you